قال الرئيس الصيني
ان تطوير العلاقه بين بلاده والولايات
المتحده يقع على عاتق الشعبين واكد شيخ
خلال لقائه مع بيل جيتس المؤسس المشارك في
شركه مايكروسوفت وهو ثالث رجل اعمال
الامريكي كبير يزور الصين خلال ثلاثه اشهر
اكد اهميه التعاون بين البلدين الذي
عرقلته خلافات بشان حقوق الانسان وتايوان
والامن والتكنولوجيا
[موسيقى]
بعد نحو اسبوعين من زياره رئيس شركه تسلا
ايلون ماسك وبعد اقل من ثلاثه اشهر من
زياره المدير العام لشركه ابل تيم كوك وصل
مؤسس ومايكروسوفت الى الصين حيث التقى
الرئيس شيت جيم بينج الذي قال ان الولايات
المتحده والصين يمكنهما تطوير التعاون
لصالح البلدين لولا خلافات بينهما بشان
حقوق الانسان وتايوان والامن والتكنولوجيا
بالجيد الذي لفت لقائه الرئيس الكثير من
المراقبين للبعد السياسي الذي اتخذته
الزياره سمع ايضا من شيجي بنك تاكيدا بان
تطوير العلاقات بين واشنطن يقع على عاتق
الشعبين تصريحات تاتي في خضم حرب تجاريه
بين الصين والولايات المتحده تتزامن
بدورها مع توتر سياسي وعسكري يسعى البلد
لاحتوائه من خلال زياره مرتقبه لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
[موسيقى]
ينضموا الينا لمناقشه هذا الموضوع من
بيجين فيكتور جاو نائب رئيس مركز الصين
والعولمه ومن واشنطن البروفيسور
المدير السابق السابق لابحاث سياسات
التجاره والتصنيع في معهد السياسه
الاقتصاديه في واشنطن ابدا معك
هذا ثالث رئيس شركه كبرى في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يزور الصين خلال فتره
زمنيه قصيره ما الدافع وراء هذه الزيارات
في هذا التوقيت
كبيرا على الصين وعلى سوق الصين
ربما هذا غير معروف ولكن الصين هي من ابرز
المستوردين لهذه اشبه الموصلات وبالتالي
هي من اكبر العملاء لهذه الشركات بالنسبه
الى حافز الصين في هذه
المحادثات يتحدثون عن تعاون بين الشعبين
هذا كلمه مرمزه من اجل
دفع هذا الشركات الكبرى للضغط على اداره
بايدن من اجل الحد من بعض التوترات
التي ذكرتم انها ترتبط بحقوق الانسان
موضوع تايوان وكذلك الصراعات
العسكريه
والتي هي اساس هذه التوترات مع الصين وهذه
النقطه احولها للسيد فيكتور سيد فيكتور
يعني هل تحاول الصين استغلالها هذه
الزيارات ذات الطابع التجاري الاقتصادي
لتحقيق مارب سياسيه
هذه زيارات من قبل قاعده مع مشهورين
ومهمين مثل
وغيره وهي مهمه نحن في الصين
والعامه الرابع والاربعين على التواري كنا
في الصين ما زلنا منفتحين على الشركات
الاجنبيه وكثيرا منهم
اكتشفوا الصين كواحده من اكبر
الاسواق وكانوا كما عثر على كنز من الذهب
وايضا ووجدوا بيئه ملائمه
ساعدتهم على توسيع نطاق اعمالهم وتسويق
منتجاتهم في اسواق اخرى في العالم لهذا
السبب مثل هذه الزيارات من قاده الاعمال
الامريكيين يبرهنوا على انه لا غنى عن
البعد البعد الاقتصادي التجاري في هذه
الزيارات معلوم ومعروف ولكن ان يلتقي ماسك
وزير الخارجيه ان يلتقي بيل غيتس الرئيس
الصيني بذاته ما هي الرساله التي تحاول
الصين ايصالها للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وللمجتمع الدولي
هل هي رساله اقتصاديه
ستضر بنفسها وتلحق الضرر بمساق الشعب
الامريكي هذا ليس اختراع صواريخ هذه مساله
بسيطه مثل بساطه حروف التهجئه الاي بي سي
طيب ينضم الينا الان من باريس محمد علي
السويسي الصحفي المتخصص في تكنولوجيا
الاتصالات سيد محمد انتم في مجال
التكنولوجيا والاتصالات كيف تراقبون هذه
الزيارات خاصه انها زيارات على مستوى رفيع
في عالم الاعمال والاتصالات
هذه الزيارات هي رساله واضحه ان عالم
الشركات التكنولوجيا الامريكيه والذي لديه
تاثير كبير في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الى هذه الساعه الى اليوم مرتبط اساسا
بالصين وهو يريد ان يثبت ان هذا الارتباط
او هذه العلاقه هي علاقه متينه الصين
بالنسبه لشركات التكنولوجيه الامريكيه
تمثل نقطتين مهمتين النقطه الاولى هي ان
الصين هي سوق لشركه الامريكيه وهي سوق
ضخمه لكن ايضا الصين هي مركز للصناعه ولو
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تحاول في
السنوات الاخيره
اعاده التموقع وتركيز صناعه
التكنولوجياتها في الهند فلذلك حضور بيل
غيتس هي رساله قويه الرجل هو احد ابرز
الرجال
الناشطين
والمؤثرين في عالم التكنولوجيا خلال قرابه
سته عقود حضوره اليوم في الصين دليل على
ان
ما نتحدث عنه من صراع سياسي صراع اقتصادي
بين الصين والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وفي الواقع امر لا يعني كثيرا رجال
التكنولوجيا وشركه التكنولوجيا الكبرى
فيما يخص علاقه شركتهم بهذا البلد طيب هنا
نعود الى السيد روبرت سيد روبرت يعني كيف
تتعاطى الاداره الامريكيه مع هذه الزيارات
استمعنا للسيد محمد علي وهو يقول بان
الصين مركز للصناعات الصين سوق رئيسيه
لهذه الشركات بينما تحاول الاداره
الامريكيه محاصره الصين
او احتواء الصين ان اردنا
ان يكون واضحا هنا هو ان ما يلائم الصين
ويناسب الشركات المتعدده الجنسيات مثل
مايكروسوفت
ليس بالضروره يصب في مصلحه الامن القومي
الامريكي
والعاملين في الولايات المتحده
خسرت الولايات المتحده اكثر من 60 الف
مصنع وخمسه ملايين وظيفه في المجال
التصنيع ولا سيما في ولايات الحزام الغربي
حيث انتقل الدعم الانتخابيه من دعم الحزب
الديمقراطي الى دعم سيد ترامب بسبب ذلك
وهذا عزز اهميه مواجهه الصين
بشان سياساتها المستمره الاستغلاليه وعدم
اعتمادها وتنفيذها قواعد التجاره العادله
والمنصفه يجب ارتاء توازن ومنع الصين من
استغلال الصناعه الامريكيه والعاملين
الامريكيين يمكننا التحدث عن ذلك بطريقه
او بطرق مختلفه ولكن هذا يضر بالاقتصاد
الامريكي وبالتالي بغض النظر عن مصلحه
تسلا او مايكروس وفت ولكن سيد روبرت سكوت
هذه هي شركات متعدده الجنسيات شركات كبرى
لديها التاثير والنفوذ داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان كانت سياسه الاداره
الامريكيه واضحه تجاه الصين كيف ستكون
تجاه هذه الشركات التي تهرول للقاء
المسؤولين الصينيين وهم يستقبلوها بترحاب
اداره الرئيس بايدن تتخذ خطوات مهمه في
محاولاتها لاستعاده حصص كبيره من السوق في
مجال التكنولوجيا مثل السيارات الكهربائيه
والشبه الموصلات
المتطوره والمعقده تتخذ خطوات من اجل ان
تصعب على الصين الاستفاده بطريقه غير
منتفه من هذه القطاعات
مايكروسوفت والتسلا تبيعاني معظم
منتجاتهما في الولايات المتحده ربما
تصنعهما في الصين او في دول تعمل معها
الصين ولكن السوق الرئيسيه هي هنا في
الولايات المتحده
بالتالي اعتقد ان مصالح الشركات الكبرى
منقسمه بين البحث عن ارباح عاليه والبحث
عن حصص في السوق واعتقد ان رئيس بايدن
يمكنه وبكل سهوله ان يتعامل مع هذه
التوترات هنا داخل الامريكي سيده فيكتور
جاو الى اي مدى
تسعى الصين الى تعميق الشرخ بين هذه
الشركات والاداره الامريكيه هي تضخم من
هذه الزيارات تحتل هذه الزيارات صداره
عناوين الاخبار ووسائل الاعلام الى اي مدى
تساهم الصين في تعميق الشرخ
اعتقد انني متفاجئ بما يقوله السيد سكوت
دعوني اضرب مثل جنرال الموترز باعت من
السيارات في الصين اكثر مما تبيعه داخل
الوقت المتحده
وكثير من الشركات الامريكيه تبيع من
منتجاتها في السوق الصيني اكثر من سوقها
الامريكيه لان السوق الصينيه اهي حجما
اربعه اضعاف السوق الامريكيه
والمبيعات اعلى من وجهه نظر الصين اذا
ارادت الراتب المتحده ام تطور من مجالها
الامر بسيط للغايه اولا عليكم ان تحسن من
البنى التحتيه تحتاجون الى طرق مواصلات
افضل الى وسائل ربط اكثر
وبدلا من معاناه كم من اثار البنيه
التحتيه المتهراهه اين تنفق امريكا مالها
على الحروب والحروب والحروب
اشرت الى ما يجب ان تفعله الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ولكن سؤالي كان في
اتجاه اخر هل تستغل الصين زياره رجال
الاعمال هذه
نعم
الصين هل تستغل هذه الزيارات لرجال اعمال
من اجل تعميق الشرخ بين الاداره الامريكيه
والشركات هذه
هل تصطاد في الماء العكر
كلا على الاطلاق
كلا على الاطلاق ليس للصين اي اهتمام او
مصلحه في الوضع السياسي الداخلي في
الولايات المتحده
الحكومه الامريكيه عليها ان تمثل مصالح
الشعب الامريكي الاساسيه واهمها الصناعات
والشركات الامريكيه واذا اراد شخص ان يقول
لي بان دعم امريكا لمؤسساتها التجاريه لا
يعني دعم القطاعات الصناعيه لا يعرفون عما
يتكلمون على رات المتحده ان تعزز من هذه
الشركات ومن اشخاص مثل
هم ركائز ودعائم رياده الاعمال والابتكار
تعود لتملي على الاداره الامريكيه كيف
عليها ان تتصرف بينما يكون السؤال فيما
يتعلق بالصين وسياسه الصين ساعود اليك
دعني اسمع من السيد محمد علي سيد محمد علي
بعيد عن الجدل في السياسه انعكاسات هذه
الزيارات على صناعه التكنولوجيا على
الصراع التكنولوجي بين الجانبين الامريكي
والصيني
طبعا فيما يخص بيل جيت لا اظن ان لهذا
الرجل تاثير كبير تكنولوجيا
يهتم اكثر بمنظمته بعمل منظماتي لكن اليوم
مايكروسوفت الشركه التي انتجها بيد
ولديها ايضا استراتيجيتها الخاصه اليوم
عندما يتحدث عن العديد من التكنولوجيات عن
الذكاء الاصطناعي عن السيارات
الكهربائيه عن وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي عن
الهواتف الذكيه وغيرهم يعني عن الاتصال
الجيل الخامس والجيل السادس نتحدث عن صراع
امريكي
والصيني ومثل هذه الزيارات تعطي للصين
الفرصه الاكبر كي تتحدث عن تكنولوجياتها
هي ارض البحث والتطوير في التكنولوجيا هي
بحث التصنيع هي بحث البراءات براءات
الاختراع التي تسجل بكميه مهوله كل يوم
وكذلك تعطي الامكانيه للصين حتى تتحدث على
انها
منفتحه على العمل مع شركه الامريكيه حضور
ايلون ماسك او بيل جيتس هو دليل على ان
الصين تتعامل
برسانه اكثر من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فيما يخص التعامل التكنولوجي
وملفات سابقه اوضحت ذلك وكانت هي الدليل
الاكبر ملفته هواوي او ملفات تيك توك
وغيرهم من القضايا الساخنه بين البلدين
قضايا التكنولوجيه كان هناك تعامل عقلاني
عقلاني اهدى من الصين من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي تعمدت التشنج والتعبئه ضد
الصين وضد شركه تتعامل عن التعامل عقلاني
للصين وهنا اعود الى السيد روبرت سيد
روبرت يعني يتحدث السيد محمد عن تعامل
عقلاني اكثر رصانا مع هذه
الشركات من الواضح بان هذه الشركات لديها
موقف مختلف عن الاداره الامريكيه وهذا ما
عبر عنه ماسك وايضا عبرت عنه الرئيس
التنفيذيه لجنرال موتورز ايضا بالتالي لمن
الغلابه هل شركات سيكون صوتها اعلى ام
الاداره الامريكيه ستكون قادره على احتواء
هذه الشركات
من سينتصر
لدي نكته هنا اولا بالنسبه الى مصالح قطاع
شركات الامريكيه فهو قطاع مختلف عن ولايات
المتحده ومصالح العميلين فيها
الفائده التجاريه الصينيه الاكبر هو مع
الولايات المتحده وبالتالي هذا ياتي
لمصلحه تسلا ومايكروسوفت شركات الكبرى هي
تجني المليارات من الارباح من خلال
تعاونها مع المصنعين والمنتجين في الصين
هنالك من يرى بان الاعمال التجاريه هي طوق
النجاه المحافظه على الاستقرار في
العلاقات بين الصين والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
اعتقد ان هذه العلاقات يجب ان تقارب على
مستوى قومي وطني وليس على مستوى شركات
الشركات تؤثر ربما على السياسه الامريكيه
ولكن لا يجب ان اترك لها قدره الاملاء على
الحكومه الامريكيه المشكله هي ان الصين
مارسات التجاره غير العاجله لما لا يقل عن
30 عاما من خلال تدمير قيمه العمله
ودعم الشركات ضد الشركات الامريكيه وهذا
كان سيئا لاقتصادنا وللعمال الامريكيين
على هذه الشركات لتحسين العلاقات الا يبدو
يعني تعويلا
اعطاء هذا التعويل اكبر من حجمه بتقديرك
مبالغ فيه
كلا ابدا الامر ليس كذلك الصين ستفتح
ابوابها دائما للعمل مع كل بلدان العالم
بما فيها الولايات المتحده وهذا مهم
كاجراء واقعي واطراقاتي ولكنه تناقض صارخ
مع الولايات المتحده الصين تسير في المسار
الصحيح الولاده المتحده في المسار الخطا
السيد اسقاط يتحدث عن عجز في ميزان
التبادل
وفائض كبير نعم هناك فائض كبير لصالح
الصين والصين تريد ان تشتري الكثير من
السلع من امريكا لكن امريكا ترفض بيعها
تحدثنا عن اشباه الموصلات والمدخلات
الاخرى الاتجاه اداره بايدن تحول دون بيع
رقائق اشباه الموصليه هذه وهي بذلك توجه
ضرب كبيره الى الصادرات الامريكيه على
منطلقون اليوم على الصين ام لا المتحده
الاجابه واضحه زيدوا من المبيعات وزيدوا
من التبادل مع الصين وجعل التوازن بين
الصين امريكا اكثر توازنا بدلا من
الصين نائب رئيس مركز الصين والعولمه كنت
معنا من بيت جين شكر موصول للبروفيسور
المدير السابق لابحاث سياسات التجاره
والتصنيع في معهد السياسات الاقتصاديه في
واشنطن ومن باريس محمد علي السويسي الصحفي
المتخصص في تكنولوجيا الاتصالات
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]